Today, we're breaking down three AB
tests for maps.
Paywalls,
ride-hailing,
bookings,
that will completely change how you
think about interface design. You're
going to love it. For each one, we're
going to show you two screens, A and B.
They look really similar. Both look
fine, but one of them performs
dramatically better.
Pause the video on each one and see if
you can spot which one won before we
explain it. If you want, keep track of
how many you guess right and let us know
in the comments at the end.
Look at these two screens. Same app,
same price, same $19 a month, same free
trial.
One of them converts much better than
the other. Pause the video and tell me
which one you think is better.
Okay, let's go. It's B. And here's the
crazy part. B doesn't even try to sell
you. That's exactly why it wins. Let me
show you what's happening. Screen A is a
classic paywall. Big hero image with
some space art, a bold headline, "Get
access to 1,000 plus futuristic and fun
games." Then the price, $19 per month.
Then three feature bullets with icons.
Instant unlimited access, new games
added weekly, members-only rewards. And
at the bottom, a big purple button that
says, "Subscribe and start 7 days for
free." It's a perfectly reasonable
screen. You've seen this layout a
hundred times. And that's the problem.
Because the moment a user sees this
screen, the brain asks one question. Is
this worth $19 a month? And that is a
brutal question to land on someone who
opened your app 30 seconds ago. They
haven't played a single game. They
haven't felt any value. And now you're
asking them to evaluate three bullet
points and decide if that's worth $19
every month for the foreseeable future.
That's not a decision. That's homework.
And the easiest answer to homework is,
I'll think about it later, which means
never.
Now, look at screen B. Same price, same
trial, but a completely different
question. The headline says, how your
free trial works, not here's what you
get, not here's why you should pay, just
[music] here's how the free thing works.
And the user's brain immediately shifts
from is this worth $19 to can I try this
for free? And the answer to that
question is obviously yes. You've gone
from a hard question to an easy one.
That's the entire game.
But the way B delivers this is where it
gets really smart.
There's a timeline. Three steps: today,
day five, day seven. And each one tells
you exactly what happens. Today, you
unlock the full library. Day five, we
send you a reminder that your trial is
ending soon. Day seven, your first
charge begins. Cancel anytime before.
Now, that day five line, that single
line is doing more psychological work
than all three feature bullets on screen
A combined. Because it says, we will
warn you before we charge you. Think
about what that communicates. It says,
we're not trying to trap you. We're
actually going to remind you so you can
make an informed decision. This triggers
something called transparency bias. When
a company proactively reveals a
potential downside, users trust them
more, not less. It feels like the
company is on your side. And a user who
trusts you is a user who converts. Now,
look at the buttons. This seems like a
tiny difference, but it's massive. The
word subscribe carries commitment's
weight. Your brain hears subscribe and
thinks recurring payment, hard to
cancel, I'm locked in. And then the
button tries to soften it with and start
7 days for free, but it's too late.
Screen B uses start. Start is light.
Start implies a beginning, not a
commitment. [music] And notice it says,
my free trial, not your free trial. My,
that one word creates a sense of
ownership before you've even tapped the
button. And then underneath, start in
two taps. This is brilliant because your
brain hates uncertainty. Will there be a
form? Do I need my credit card? How many
steps? Start in two taps kills every
single one of those questions with a
number. Not quick setup, not easy setup,
the number does the convincing. It's the
same reason delivery in 23 minutes
converts better than fast delivery.
Specificity is trust. Look at the hero
images. Screen A has this beautiful
space illustration with planets and
meteors. It's gorgeous, but it's
decorative. It does not answer the
question, what am I actually getting?
Screen B shows actual game characters.
Different games, different styles, all
visible. The user can immediately see
what they're subscribing to, and you
can't commit to something you can't
visualize. So, here's the full picture.
Screen A asks a hard question. Screen B
asks an easy one. Screen A lists
features. Screen B shows a timeline.
Screen A says subscribe, Screen B says
start. Screen A hopes you'll trust them,
Screen B proves they're trustworthy by
promising to remind you before they
charge you. Same app, same price, same
offer. But one feels like a sales pitch
and the other feels like a safety net.
And users don't buy from sales pitches,
they buy from safety nets. The best
paywall is the one that makes the user
feel safe, not sold. Today we have
something exciting to share. We are
launching UX Peak Plus, a new design
learning platform that teaches the
advanced UX and UI skills designers
actually need today. Most design
education still teaches the same basics,
how to pick a typeface, how to space
your buttons, and how to use Figma. And
those things matter, but they're not
what's actually holding designers back.
You don't need another lesson on
typography. You need to understand how
top e-commerce sites design product
pages that actually convert.
How the best apps onboard new users so
they stick around past day one.
The pricing psychology top SaaS
companies use to drive conversion.
And how to use AI the way top designers
use it to move faster, design better,
and stay ahead. The real advanced stuff
designers need to know in 2026 that
nobody else is teaching. That's what UX
Peak Plus is. We break down how top
companies like Spotify, Notion, Airbnb,
and Duolingo actually design their
products. It's the kind of learning that
makes you genuinely better. The kind
that gets you promoted, makes your
designs convert, and gets people to
actually use what you built. We're also
releasing a new course every week. So,
for every month you're a member, you get
four new courses added to your library.
But, you don't have to decide blindly.
You can start for free at uxpeak.com
with free course and no credit card
required. And if you decide to join, use
code UX Peak 20 to get 20% off with our
launch offer. You'll also have a 7-day
money-back guarantee. So, if it's not
for you, there's no risk. Now, let's get
back into the second example. Okay, so
in the last tip, we talked about how the
words on your paywall change whether
someone subscribes or bounces. But, what
happens when the problem isn't the
words? It's the number. Not how much you
charge, how you show it. Look at these
two ride-hailing screens. Same ride,
same route,
same Tuesday afternoon. One of them gets
significantly more bookings. The other
one was actually losing the company
money. And this time it's tricky because
the one that looks more honest is the
one that fails. Pause the video and tell
me which one you think won.
It's B. And no, it's not because it's
cheaper. The average fare is almost
identical. The difference is entirely in
how the price is presented. Version A
shows price ranges. Go X $13 to $17,
Comfort $17 to $22, Go XL $16 to $21.
Feels honest, right? Except your brain
doesn't process ranges the way you think
it does.
When you see 13 to 17, you don't think
probably 15. You grab the high number,
17. That's called anchoring. Now Go X
feels like a $17 ride you might get
lucky and pay 13 for. And you're doing
that mental negotiation on three options
simultaneously. Go X could be 17,
Comfort could be 22, Go XL could be 21.
Too many unknowns, too many what ifs.
And the easiest decision becomes no
decision. Close the app, just walk.
Version A asks, "How much are you
willing to risk?" Version B asks, "Which
one do you want?" Easy questions get
fast answers. One number per ride, no
range, no negotiation. Your brain
compares three clear prices in about 2
seconds. Researchers call this
evaluative ease. The less work a
decision requires, the more likely
someone is to make it. But B does more.
Under Go X it says 12:53 p.m., 2 minutes
away. This reframes a cost decision into
a convenience decision. You're not
evaluating a price anymore. A car is 2
minutes away and it costs less than
lunch.
Then there's a tiny green badge that
says cheaper. One word. Doesn't say
cheaper than what. Your brain reads it
and immediately categorizes this as the
smart choice. A single green word did
the thinking for you. And one more.
There's a destination card on the map
before you even see the ride options.
The Westin St. Francis, San Francisco.
That's commitment consistency. You
already decided where you're going. The
only question left is which car. And
that's a much smaller decision than
should I take a ride at all. If you're
showing users a range when you could
[music] show them a number, you're not
being transparent. You're creating
doubt, and doubt is the most expensive
thing in your interface. You probably
know this feeling. You need to design
something, maybe a paywall, checkout
flow, onboarding screen, booking flow.
So, you go looking for inspiration.
Maybe you open Dribbble and everything
looks beautiful, but the problem is you
don't know if it was actually shipped,
tested, or used in the real world.
Pretty UI can inspire how something
looks, but real product screens can
teach you if something really works.
That's why we used Mobbin for creating
this video. We've looked at hundreds of
different paywall screens and booking
screens to give you the best tips.
Mobbin gives you a huge library of real
mobile and web app screens. You can
search for paywalls, onboarding,
checkout flows, cancellation flows, and
compare how different apps structure the
same moment. So, if you're a designer,
founder, or product person, Mobbin is
genuinely one of the best tools for
that. We use it ourselves, and that's
why we partnered with Mobbin to give you
an exclusive 20% discount on your first
year. You can get 20% off simply by
clicking the link in the description.
So far we've talked about how the words
on your screen change behavior and how
the way you show a number changes
whether someone buys or bounces.
But, what happens when the words are
fine and the numbers are fine, and it
still doesn't convert?
>> [music]
>> That's when the problem isn't what
you're showing, it's how it makes them
feel. Look at these two booking screens.
Same villa, same price, 89 euros a
night, same dates,
same beds, same bathroom.
One of these gets dramatically more
bookings than the other. Pause the video
and tell us which one.
Got it? It's B. And this one is
important because screen A does
absolutely nothing wrong.
The title is clear, the rating is
visible, the price is big, the dates are
there, the reserve button works. If you
showed this to a designer, they'd say,
"Yeah, that's fine." And that's exactly
the problem. Fine doesn't book villas.
Look at what screen A actually gives
you. A nice photo of the villa but
tucked into a small thumbnail at the
top, almost like it's afraid to take up
space. Beach house with garden, 4.82
stars, 89 euros per night, check in
March 28, check out April 2, two guests,
reserve. That's a form. You're filling
out a form and nobody has ever felt
excited about filling out a form. Now
look at screen B. Same exact photo but
the photo isn't squeezed into a small
thumbnail anymore taking over the top
half of the screen. You're not looking
at a listing card. You're looking at a
place you might actually go. There are
navigation badges, super host,
guest favorite,
one of 24 photos.
You haven't read a single word and you
already feel something. [music] That's
the difference. Screen A informs you,
screen B transports you.
Then the title. Screen A says beach
house with garden. Screen B says beach
side escape steps from the sand. Same
place but beach side escape activates
emotional imagination. Steps from the
sand gives you a specific spatial
detail. You don't have to walk for 10
minutes to reach the beach. This is
sensory language. It makes you feel like
you're already on holiday before you've
even checked the price. Now the price.
Screen A just shows 89 euros. There's no
reference point. Screen B shows 129
euros crossed out then 89 with a green
minus 31% [music] badge. Same price but
now it feels like a deal. That's
anchoring working for you instead of
against you which is exactly what we
talked about in the last tip. The dates.
Screen A shows two input fields, March
28 and April 2. Screen B shows Friday,
March 28 to Wednesday, April 2 with the
purple badge that says five nights. Day
names make the trip feel real. You're
already planning your Friday arrival and
the night count saves you the mental
math. Every piece of friction you remove
is a reason to keep going.
The button. Screen A [music] says
reserve. Reserve what? For how much
total? Screen B says reserve 445 euros
total. The total is right there. No
anxiety about hidden fees on the next
screen. And underneath, a green shield
that says free cancellation before March
26. The number one booking objection is
what if my plans change? That single
line answers it before the user even
asks. Three tips in and the pattern is
the same every time. That is all for
today.
If you take one thing from this video,
take this. Every element on your screen
is asking the user a question. And the
question you're asking determines
whether they act or hesitate. That's the
whole thing. Once you start seeing it,
you can't unsee it. And your designs get
better immediately.
If one of these tips surprised you, we'd
love to hear which one. Also, let us
know in the comments if you'd like to
see more of these. Thanks for watching.